i need to make a lifeguard
but anyway the the the thing that i'm
i'm thinking if they're taping right
next door we could just walk down the
street
unannounced and ask if nothing else
he'll tell me to go [ __ ] myself
this might be good too either way this
is exciting
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
ask us to get up from here and will you
guys start your phone follow me down the
street and let's see if rob dierdick
will be ah dear dick what
bob
bobby bobby yeah
you don't know who this is i have no
[ __ ] ideas
i love him he's one of my favorites
well good luck getting
that guy yeah who who the guy from
ridiculous
yeah okay
that's it's a ridiculous idea who's your
favorite person on mtv uh uh oh you know
the the one i really wanna say carson
daly is is uh
uh
spooky the name is spooky that's the
nickname
i i
spooky
johnson
spooky johnny spooky johnson and
spooky is very scary guy
so knowing that and knowing that you're
such a fan of spooky johnson's right
when we go next door and we talk to rob
if he's willing to do the show we'll ask
him to get a spooky johnson autograph
for you that would be [ __ ] awesome
all right follow me if you will okay
let's go i'll see
because you don't a lot of people will
book guests through agents and stuff i
go door to door that's the beauty of me
the thing is i'm doing a show next door
i don't have a guess i'm trying to get
rob to come next door and do
do my podcast
i love rob you know this is
ridiculousness that he's taping here and
the fact that i don't have a guest and i
just go next door and say will you be on
the podcast it's ridiculous can you hear
him he's caught he's got him on the
watch talk
howie mandel i heard that now they're
saying it there yeah hi
howie mandel
is rob here what's
up oh you're in the middle of filming
what's going on i'm doing a podcast oh
you're doing a podcast yeah
put it on over there if you have a
couple minutes
[Music]
say that again i can't hear you there's
a jet
we're doing a contest right now i'm
doing a podcast right now yeah you know
around personally
yeah we're really good friends
hello
rob
howie mandel
hey buddy
i'm a huge fan of games buddy
well right next door i do a podcast this
is my son alex
say hi alex hey hello i'm doing a
podcast and i don't have a booker like i
don't have i didn't hire anything i
don't have a stop loss
i got nothing you want to come next door
into a podcast
i mean did you know we were on lunch
no no so bring it bring this to sandwich
or something you want to come yeah i'll
do it all right
so it's just uh
do you have a minute yeah i guess all
right whatever you have whatever tell
them to call you i don't care
[Music]
that's ridiculousness
whatever we want to go yeah
hi
it's great hello
oh you're part of the show yeah
everybody
the show already started this is howie
mandel howie mandel does stuff and you
are tell him on the mic
and that's my buddy lou by the way how
are you lou how are you really good okay
and and this is everybody knows rob
dierdick
who who
well because we're running a gun and i
just went next door because somebody
said we don't have a guest
today they always say that yeah and i
said well did anybody phone anybody and
they said nobody phoned anybody and then
they said well you know he tapes uh
ridiculousness right next door
so as luck would have it
and it wasn't enough just to have your
daughter with you
you had to go get a guess why you're
jealous of the guests
you know what i got to tell you
something rob before we get talking you
guys are live she was on your show we
should show that clip jeremy you don't
know yes tell me at her wedding
at her wedding to the young mr schultz
yes yes yeah yes um she uh drank a lot
ah and she was uh puking in the do you
you you guys and then was that real it
was a video from ridiculousness no it
was real real it was real real
real so you do ridiculousness um is that
the one who who was the guest on that
one so that he can look up the alex was
on it too
you feel better
what the what what did you do tonight
alex you can't leave me now
[Music]
you're the bride right
yeah and talk about how beautiful
tonight was i have urine all over my
chin
okay you don't even love her he hold her
hair he lifts him
up
i'm gonna be divorced in no time i'll
tell you what i will do is i will film
you okay so that you can understand how
you ruined my wedding
alex was on it god
i love you man you're making you're like
emily puke session is whatever
she threw up in the bridal suite after
the the and you made fun of the fact
that we were videotaping it she called
me
she got married
they went off to their room after the
wedding and then her husband called me
and said uh how you got to get back i
mean i've just given away the bride
don't give him back
this is no returns on this ah and then
and uh and then uh he said she's sick
and we had to hold her hair while she
was puking which makes you puke like
puke
that's hey this is a very very true
statement
[Music]